of all the characters in all the disney
films
the one i love the most is jiminy
cricket from pinocchio
my favorite scene in the movie is when
the blue fairy is saying to pinocchio
always let your conscience be your guide
pinocchio asks what are conscious and
jiminy cricket is scandalized by the
question what are conscience
what are conscience conscience is that
still
small voice that people won't listen to
that's just the travel with the world
today
i love the way jiminy cricket is always
there
with a nerdy ethical thing
just as pinocchio's coming up with some
kind of good plan
i think of him as speaking truth to
puppet i always
wondered what it was about jiminy
cricket that made me love him so much
and one day it hit me was because
he sounds like my grandfather
my grandfather was a very sweet and
cuddly man and i
loved him to the moon and back but i
shared him with a big wide world his
name was roy o'disney
and together with his younger brother
walt disney he came
from a very humble upbringing in kansas
and started and ran one of the most
iconic businesses in the world
two things i remember the best about
going to disneyland with my grandfather
the first thing was he always gave me a
stern warning
that if i ever sassed anybody who worked
there i was in deep duty when we got
home
he said these people work really hard
harder than you can imagine
and they deserve your respect the other
is
that he never walked by a piece of
garbage inside of disneyland or anywhere
else where he didn't bend over to pick
it up
he said no one's too good to pick up a
piece of garbage
in grandpa's day a job at disneyland was
not a gig
a person could expect to own a home
raise a family
access decent health care retire in some
security
without worrying on just what he earned
there
at the park mind you grandpa [ __ ] the
unions
and he fought them hard he said he
didn't like to be forced to do something
he wanted to do voluntarily
that was frank paternalism of course and
maybe even a tiny bit of bs
he wasn't an angel and everyone wasn't
well and fairly treated across the
company
something that's well known
but i think in his core he had
a very deep commitment to the idea that
he had a moral obligation to every human
being that worked for him that actually
wasn't such an uncommon attitude for
ceos of the day
but when my grandfather died in 1971
a new mindset was beginning to take hold
of the american and
eventually the global imagination jiminy
cricket got shown the door by
economist milton friedman among others
who
popularized the idea of shareholder
primacy
now shareholder primacy is a pretty
reasonable idea
when you think about it shareholders own
the company
shareholders want profits and growth
so therefore you prioritize profits and
growth
very sensible but unfortunately
shareholder primacy was
an idea that became a mindset and then
that mindset jumped the rails
and it came to fundamentally alter
everything
about the way companies and even
governments were led
and managed milton friedman's pivotal
op-ed in the new york times
was followed by decades of concerted
organizing
and lobbying by business-focused
activists
along with a sustained assault on
every law and regulation that had once
held
businesses worst impulses in check
and soon enough this new mindset had
taken hold
across every business school and across
every sector
profits were to be pursued by any means
necessary
unions were kneecapped taxes were
slashed and with the same machete so
was the safety net i don't need to tell
you about the inequality that's been the
result of these shifts
we all know the story well the bottom
line is that everything that turns a gig
into a livelihood
was stripped away from an american
worker
job security paid sick days vacation
time
all of that went away even as the
wealthy saw their net worth
bloat to unprecedented and yes
unusable levels although if you're
scrooge mcduck you could change it all
into gold coins and backstroke through
it
so let me just address the dumbo in the
room
yes i am criticizing the company that
bears my family's name
yes i think disney can do better and i
believe
that many of the thousands of
magnificent people who work at the walt
disney company
wish that it would do better just as
much as i do
for almost a century disney has turned a
pretty profit
on the idea that families are a kind of
magic
that love is important that imaginations
matter
that's why it turns your stomach a
little bit when i tell you that
cinderella might be sleeping in her car
but let's be very clear this is not just
about disney
this is structural and this is systemic
no single ceo on his own is culpable
and no single company has the
wherewithal to buck this
the analysts the pundits the politicians
the business school curricula
and the social norms that drive the
shape of the contemporary economy
disney is just doing what everybody else
does and they're not even the worst
offender
if i told you how bad it was for workers
at amazon or mcdonald's or walmart
or any one of a thousand other places
you've never heard of
it's not going to hit you as viscerally
as if i tell you that 73
or 3 out of 4 of the people who smile
when you walk in
who help you comfort that crying baby
who maybe help you have the best
vacation you ever have
can't consistently put food on the table
it's supposed to be the happiest place
on earth
and the people who work there take
incredible pride
that they pursue a higher purpose it's a
higher purpose that both my grandfather
and great uncle
very intentionally built when they made
it a place that honors
an interaction over a transaction
now i know that a word like magic makes
you wonder if i've taken leave of my
senses
i know it's hard to imagine that
something as ephemeral as
love can support a brand as big as
disney
and i know that it's hard to imagine
that things as
unquantifiable as moral obligations
should have any call on us when we seek
to deliver
value to our investors but accounting
and finance
don't run the world beliefs
mindsets those are what drive business
ethics
and if we're going to change those
mindsets and belief systems
we're going to have to use the most
disney superpower out there
we're going to have to use our
imaginations you're going to have to
invite too many
cricket back to the party
now jiminy cricket might start with some
low-hanging fruit
like greed is not good like the world is
not divided into makers intakers
and that nobody ever without any help
pulled themselves up by their own
bootstraps if you know anything about
physics you'll understand why that is
jiminy might remind us that every single
person who works for us
without exception whether they fill out
the spreadsheets
or change the bed sheets deserves the
respect and dignity a
living wage it's as simple as that
and jiminy might wonder how managers and
employees can possibly have any kind of
empathy for each other
when their workplaces have become so
segregated that it seems normal and
natural
that an executive needs especially
swanky place to park or eat or go to the
bathroom
or that an executive is too good to pick
up a piece of garbage
we are after all just the one species
living together on just the one planet
jiminy might ask us to question some of
our dogma
does a ceo really need to be paid as
much or more than
every other ceo or is that just creating
a competitive dynamic that's driving
numbers into the stratosphere
he might wonder if boards really do know
all that they really need to know when
they don't have frontline workers
ever at their meetings he might ask if
there's such a thing
as too much money or he might wonder if
maybe we can make common cause
with consumers with workers with
companies with communities
for all of us to come together to
redefine this incredibly
narrow idea of what it is the purpose of
a company
really is jiminy would want us to
remember
that nobody works in a vacuum that the
men and women who run
companies actively co-create the reality
we
all have to share and just like with
global warming
we are each of us responsible for the
collective consequences
of our individual decisions and actions
i believe that the most profitable
business ecosystem in the history of the
world can do better
i believe we can take just a little bit
off of the upside
take a tiny bit of pressure off the
speed at which things
are happening i believe that everything
we lose in the short term
will more than make up for itself in an
expanded landscape of
moral spiritual and financial prosperity
i know what the cynics say and it's true
you can't take your principles
but you can't breathe a basis point
either and neither can your children
i know i idolized my grandfather
probably too much
he worked at very different times and
those are times none of us wants to go
back to for all kinds of good reasons
i know there are a lot of ceos today who
are just as well-meaning and just as
decent as my grandfather was
but they're working at a time with very
different expectations
and much more cutthroat context but
here's the good news
expectations and contexts are made
and they can be unmade too there is so
much to learn
from the simple integrity of how my
grandfather understood his job as ceo
behind every theme park and every
stuffed animal
a handful of principles governed
everything
every single person deserves respect and
dignity
no one is too good to pick up a piece of
garbage
and always let your conscience be your
guide
we could all do worse than listen to
jiminy cricket
thank you